évidemment il lui fallait quand même une
partenaire qui soit à la fois coriace
costaude et téméraire je les trouvais et
c'est notre amie isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
est costaude un bon mais sans plus
tarder ce soir on va voir si la force
est avec vous êtes prête à oui à quoi la
boîte magique
attention là dedans alors c'est
l'équivalent d'une navette spatiale or
regardez c'est très simple but bordelais
rentrés à l'intérieur la dure helmand
oui j'avoue c'est à ces petits messieurs
crème
c'est à ces petits mais vous n'étiez pas
on a installé huit filles pas de souci
le gala l'intérieur a les jeux at on pas
aller on ferme le tout une et deux
années très très bien pas besoin de
vaisseau pour voyager et c'est
aujourd'hui c'est à ce moment que tout
se passe nous avons confectionné sur
mesure des des boucliers anti atomique
pour lutter contre les astéroïdes oui ça
peut traverser le studio vous croyez pas
regardez les premiers sont hissés up en
acier inoxydable rien évidemment à
l'intérieur et cela peut-être protéger
notre isabelle moret des boss est
normalement avec un peu de fluidité
regarder sans rentrer ce magnifique
encore plus compliqué avec le deuxième
là on joue en acier une finale et on le
place à l'intérieur
alors on blessés on va essayer
évidemment alors de rentrer à la pièce
mais je crois que l ai lâché pour sa
part est un à coup de pied damon nantes
abbas et s'habille comme je suis entré
d'agla n'agit que souhaite le plus
longue apporte quelques sabre laser et
sa façon l'attention musée cas sans
savoir le bruit du laser voilà c'est
très bien mais ça passe à l'intérieur et
les lunes
on va essayer de complexifier les
situations on aura ajouté qu on man
quelques-uns se passe à l'intérieur
papa paul bailliart à présent isabelle a
été complètement pulvérisée en poussière
des toits
ne vous inquiétez pas elle est là dans
le firmament je vais juste invoqué
l'esprit d'esprit de yoda isa ouverture
[Applaudissements]
incroyable et pour vérifier et la
connectivité
regardez il ya évidemment rien là
derrière sa venue
[Applaudissements]
finalement alors on va faire les
remettre un par un les sabres mais
croyez moi
zabel on la connaît elle est un peu sur
la lune
on va tenter de la ramener sur terre
mais pour celà j'invoque l'esprit et
yoda et ça mais oui l'eau va mal on se
débrouille plutôt bien on enlève les
cerveaux des serres et maintenant j'ai
besoin de votre attention à vos très
vite à votre doux isa bas débutée
débarqué elle est encore ici
elle est par là elle est peut-être dans
l'espace intersidéral qui lie le vdev
les est-ce que vous avez une idée
peut-être pourquoi pas sur un futon
pluton très bien très bien une telle
planète
alors oui elle est d'ailleurs c'est la
taille a fait mentir la première chose
les boucliers anti astéroïdes et oui tel
boulot c'est le feu oui quasi ce match
monsieur jean-pierre question je vous
prie mais pourquoi vous voulez la faire
revenir m
c'est une excellent camarade succession
de mots parfois un peu raté d'autant que
les vôtres d'ailleurs en tout cas on va
voir si notre un magma
il est temps que le voyage se termine
alors que l'intérieur
j'entends la petite voix jusque se faire
couper en deux et bien au maximum
[Applaudissements]
là
c'est la première fois est la première
fois qu on me fait un laser sans
l'épilation qui va avec